one thing Chris I want to start with I
noticed this from USA Today recent story
delving into the coaching career of
Steve Belichick the 32 year old son of
Patriots coach Bill Belichick and uh it
raises a bunch of issues for me and and
it all comes back to the concept of
nepotism in coaching and a lot of people
don't like the idea that coaches hire
their kids they think there's something
wrong with coaches hiring their kids as
a general proposition do you have an
issue with coaches exercising their
prerogative as they fill out a staff to
give a job to one of their kids or as a
favor to a buddy who coaches another
team that guy's kids I I don't it's a
tough subject now do I think it affects
you know the fact the fact of maybe lack
of minority head coaches and things like
that yeah I do because of course you're
having family members take jobs that are
available but you know it is for the
most part you know the family business
for a lot of these coaches and their and
their sons if they do have an interest
in football to where this is all day you
know eat you know just think about eat
live breathe every day is football
football football and we see it in a lot
of other walks of life whether a guy was
hey this guy's successful on Wall Street
know his dad worked on Wall Street or
this guy's a good doctor oh his dad was
a doctor I mean that happens in everyday
life I have more issues with Oh y-you
know I saw this when I was in the NFL
you know hey how did you get this job in
the front office oh my dad's the owners
lawyer or my dad's the owners doctor I
have more issues with those people than
I do family members family members I can
understand I really can and I do think
there is some value to it nonetheless
and you know yeah as much as it can be
unsettling that way you know I don't
know if I have a big problem with it I
think it happens for three reasons first
because so many of these teams are
family owned businesses where there's
grooming of the next generation to
eventually take over and involvement by
the next gen
raishin and other relatives sure would
feel hypocritical for the owners to say
the coaches can't hire their kids to
write don't do is we do do as we say
that just isn't gonna fly and and it's
easier to justify when ownership is rife
with nepotism secondly for a lot of
these coaches they're making up for all
those Lost years where dad was always at
work dad couldn't come to the game dad
couldn't come to the recital where is
dead that's dad I haven't seen dad in
months now all of a sudden you're with
dad all the time I think that's a big
factor you're making up for the whole
cat's in the cradle phenomenon that
plays out for coaches all over the green
and then finally and look and I thought
of this when I read some comments from
your buddy Kyle Shanahan
I think Super Bowl week when you have
been a coach's kid you bring to the
table a valuable set and experience
you're not freaked out by it you've been
around in your whole life there's
nothing about of the soup big for you
it's the Patrick mahomes dynamic why is
he so calm cool and collected because
he's been in clubhouses major league
baseball his whole life it's not too big
for him I think that is a huge value
that takes it apart from nepotism I mean
look you just happen to be in the right
place at the right time you had the
right dad you were able to come to the
office a couple of days a week and get
yourself to the point where none of this
stuff freaks you out yeah well I think I
mean you're right I agree with you on
all your points and I think that's what
people lose you know you know lose sight
of the the facts of the matter here you
know these are not like coaches sons
where you just go and like oh he's never
paid attention to football in his life
and we're gonna bring him on that we're
gonna bring him on the you know on the
coaching staff and let him have a say
now even though he has no clue what's
going on no more you know almost always
these guys are highly qualified
individuals because of what I said
earlier it's what they grew up around
it's their their experience they've been
around that way of life they're nuanced
and you know some of those tiny details
that we wouldn't even think about as
outsiders and what it takes to run an
organization and being head coach that
way you know hey Sean McVeigh is he
pretty good oh well he had a connection
I know wasn't his father
but his grandfather got him in the NFL
right oh he was worth he's worth it he's
obviously hey how about Jim fossil son
oh he's only been like the best special
teams coach in football for a long time
running here so you know Kyle Shanahan
the exact same thing so yes these are
smart people who grew up around it know
every little detail about coaching and
what it takes and how to communicate so
they're very qualified I have like I
said much I don't really have an issue
with that part of it I am more of an
issue of like I said the guy who's got
no clue he's never been involved in
football or any shape of life but his
dad knows the owner and a my son wants
to work in football okay here's a job
have you any background no I just want
to do it oh okay that to me is what
bothers me more than anything in
football that takes jobs away from the
guys that are qualified to get it so you
know I'm all for it it's the family
business for a lot of these people and
and I think that it makes it even more
incumbent on the person who gets the job
due to a family relationship or some
other connection where somebody knows
somebody you got to come in and bust
your ass it's gonna be glaring exactly
or somebody who got it in the in the
unconventional manner based upon who
they know not what they know you got to
come in and show what you know and what
you can do are you're not gonna be there
for very long and when you are there
you're gonna be the one that everybody
else resents and and doesn't fit because
yeah we know we know why Steve's here
Steve's here cuz dad's the head coach
but Steve doesn't know a damn thing of
what he's doing now as a relates to
Steve Belichick and the article that we
wrote about it and I encourage you to
read our article and read the original
article at USA Today
he clearly has the chops he clearly is
on the fast track
he clearly has the DNA and the work
ethic and everything to be another Bill
Belichick and before too long bill will
be retired and Steve will be the one
competing for Super Bowl championships
Chris yeah that's a very real
possibility I mean you know hey listen I
was around Stephen a little bit he's
smart he's a really hard worker and I
think he's trying to you know stay in
his father's shadow you know not not to
be a kiss-ass or anything like that but
he
he wants to learn every little thing
that his dad is thinking about during a
week or before a game I remember us
being on the super but on the field in
Super Bowl in Minnesota with the Eagles
and and New England Patriots Belichick
walks out on the field you know as the
players are just getting out there and
he he has his little you know
checkpoints he checks the field he walks
around he looks at the different things
bill you know Stephen Belichick was
right there next to him every step of
the way
so he could understand what dad's
processes so I get it
the big question is you know is he gonna
take over in New England does he need to
go somewhere else like a Kyle Shanahan
went somewhere else and proved himself
as one of the best offensive
coordinators at football with the
Houston Texans then he went and worked
for his dad with the Washington Redskins
this one's a little different and you
know I guess in my heart of hearts I
almost want to say I wish Stephen
Belichick would go somewhere else at
some point to just show everybody his
Worth and how good he really is or he
just hangs around until Bill retired a
big so over I mean this was the first
year I started to get a sense that maybe
Steve's the one who takes over for Bill
not josh mcdaniels did you get that
sense this year I I definitely I feel
like that's why josh mcdaniels got into
the coaching head coach coaching
conversation that maybe he saw a little
bit of the writing on the wall there
that ooh Steve Belichick is rising up
the ranks and I might you know be the
one left without a seat here added to
the fact that you know I think there's a
number of people in football that look
at it right now and think that Belichick
kind of screwed over Josh McDaniels and
the coaching hirings this year anyways
making him stay in the building didn't
let him go down the Carolina and
interview right
you know never got a chance to interview
with the New York Giants so you know
those are things I look at too and go
man how could Josh be real happy with
Bill Belichick at this point right now
and I think that would even favor
Stephen Belichick even more yeah they
get through the father-son thing for as
long as Bill wants to coach and then
when bills done coaching Steve takes
over the other curveball here though
there are some people who think that
Bill Belichick will end his career as an
executive a Bill Parcells type not that
that ever works
it didn't work for Tom Coughlin's it
really didn't work for Bill Parcells but
there's a there's a thought that that
bill gets a little slice of equity and
is like the VP of football operations
for another team if that would ever
happen with the team other than the
Patriots I could see him wanting to hire
Steve and that would be so yeah if it
would play out that way yeah sure yeah I
get that I don't see Bill doing that
though I don't I think bill is he would
be frustrated just being the GM EVIC why
are you coaching him to do this why
aren't you doing that and I just think
he's got to be in total control and when
he feels like he can't do that he'll
retire but if his son was the head coach
that could be different you're right it
would be easier to sell that right no
doubt no doubt
but bull will say look there's no reason
for him to stop he's one he's the
greatest of all time and you know he had
at one point said he can't see himself
coaching when he's 70 it's easy to say
that when you're not 70 now that he's
staring 70 in the face I think he's
gonna keep coaching for a while
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports